what fan have I ever slept on wait wait  wait wait okay say it again what do you  think he's supposed to do no he's  shooting out on purpose like that that  much closer you're gonna get your nose  bro that's what I'm saying  isn't that crazy yeah but it's multiple  girls do you see how that works but what  were you saying what was the story you  have sex with a lot of fans or something  like that no fans you've never had sex  with a fan of the fun not one time I  hooked you up with a fan of the pot you  just couldn't close she had a boyfriend  so you've never slept with a fan of the  pot or like a fan of the stand-up  not one time I met a girl stop [ __ ]  my fans bro that's just I want everyone  to say not one